[Musique]
j'ai pas
bien des tâches
[Musique]
ap
ça froid ici sur un panneau aa
transformé en bâtonnets que ça fait
quinze fois qu'on leur dit d'arrêter la
prime mais non ils font plaisir et
devenir un pic à glace comme à la chaux
c'est bien sûr nouvelle en pvc le bac
comme le dit la productrice puisqu'elle
a pas écouté mes explications
1.2.3 voilà elle doit être en train de
bouffer fusionnelle stade le cul non
mais vraiment vous pouvez même pas
savoir quoi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
maintenant voilà baltard emmenez moi on
va vous amener mais a plus tard parce
que là on est short vraiment là on est
choqué je les sens les ans mais je sens
comme ça tu vas sortir mon cul ture
aujourd'hui oui il ya une séquence qui a
fait le buzz sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est shakira qui est en train de
chanter tranquillou voilà voilà tu es tu
capable engagement will be quiet fabien
cgt tout blond a way to coup scorsese
jeune jay 2010 jugent pas voir son
numéro un arrête-toi a bien sûr j'amène
lagerfeld dicaprio et bleu donne
jatuporn dicaprio on appellera dicaprio
voir la fin de la semaine tu verras la
pana semaine mais non mais on parie
qu'il peut l'avoir nié tout cas pas si
avant la fin d'émission à d'accord mais
bon ok cependant avant la fin de mission
je me sens tout encore là bas il ya
quelqu'un qui passe son temps à
ferrières les autres chroniqueurs comme
un sale gosse
[Musique]
m
je vais répondre à l'eau ces bagarres un
[ __ ] quand j'étais avec ma femme quand
ces textes a dit d'ailleurs police et
l'eau merci tu viens de recevoir un
message de fatou à j'aime pas ta gueule
avec toi ça dans le cul ça désinfecter
isabelle tu peux passer ta chatte son
nom son animal
ça va les chevilles
ah ouais voilà
bon allons celle là
[Musique]